can you talk about filmmakers work ethic
I know you've mentioned before I think
it was on our radio show that you would
actually clock your work like a time
clock almost like an attorney does from
working on a certain client yeah you
know filmmaking especially independent
filmmaking is so challenging because I
think a lot of jobs if you're good at
them if you work really hard and if
you're smart about the work you do you
can make a living doing them or you can
make a lot of money doing them and
sometimes in filmmaking you can do all
those things and not be making any money
so to me you know I knew that I felt
like I had to be working really hard at
this in addition to having a strategy
and having ability and you know that the
work itself is not going to get done
unless you spend the time doing it and
I'm big on analytics and sort of you
know numbers cutting through your
subjective impression of yourself and
especially as somebody who runs a
website again I need to know how much
time I'm spending running that website
versus how much time I'm spending
working on my screenplay and to not let
you know the everyday tasks that you
need to do like answering email and the
you know dozen different things I do for
the film school to push aside the the
other work that you're doing so that's
why I track hours so that I can be
honest with myself about you know if I
think well last month I worked really
hard on this thing I can go look at it
and say oh no you didn't you know or I
can say I'm you know I'm co-writing
another screenplay am i letting that
overtake this project or you know if I
am consulting you're working with
somebody else you know how much time am
i spending on that and how much is that
taking away from you know manchild in my
project so I think that's our most
limited resources time and there
that's the most valuable thing to track
it seems like we all have this level to
varying degrees of adult a.d.d with
Twitter and Facebook and everybody
checking different things and even when
you check email now there's incoming
news headlines and things like that so
how do you minimize distractions for
yourself what are some of the tips and
what are your biggest distractions you
know I think we all struggle with this
especially now with email and you know
feeling like we should be on social
media and available when I'm doing my
best at it is when I'm batching these
things so I'll go carve out a four-hour
chunk to work on a screenplay where you
know you can use an application like on
the map is something called freedom
where you shut off your internet it
won't let you on the internet unless you
you know restart your computer and then
you know you feel terrible about
yourself because you couldn't stay off
the internet for four hours what kind of
you know what kind of screenwriter are
you so I think you know when you win if
you're able to step back from it and
think about do I really need to be on my
email you know once every half hour or
more the answer is no you know so I
think sort of managing your time in that
sense and carving out large chunks of
time where you're not available is that
the key thing to being productive I
think but you know I struggled with it
in the same way that everybody else does
and you know when you're when you're
going and checking your email for the
third time in 10 minutes it's just it
can be really hard so I think sometimes
having those tools and that separation
you know what did that be physically
getting up and going somewhere else and
making sure you don't get distracted all
those approaches can help but it's
definitely a challenge that like all of
us face
you